[Music]
if you think that earning money is the
only goal you will end up doing things
every day that you don't like doing to
earn money and to live a life doing
things you don't like is such a
ridiculous thing to
[Music]
do nearly 200,000 people arrive in
Australia every year as my
migrants onethird of the small
businesses are owned by
migrants we wanted to find out what
makes them do what they do what is their
motivation what challenges do they face
and after all these systemic odds and
hassles is it really worth
[Music]
it I think it's takes a certain kind of
person who's got a real tolerance for
risk to be an entrepreneur or just kind
of really wants to have that to own
their own narrative everything around
you look around you every single thing
that you're wearing every single piece
of furniture around you every single
building around you they're all been
made by entrepreneurs entrepreneurs are
nothing but creators right so we need
creators in this world because only
people who create can make the world a
better
place entrepreneur is a very different
animal I would say someone who thinks
differently someone who sees the world
differently as an entrepreneur you will
have a very unique way of looking at
things Melbourne has one of the most
vibrant Multicultural communities in
Australia and we were about to meet four
entrepreneurs to hear their
[Music]
[Applause]
stories one day my boss told me like
Drop okay stop everything stop
everything come with me you need to
understand why we do what we do she
brought me to this beach cleanup but the
organizers actually didn't want to call
it the clean up it was a beach audit
true enough an hour after we cleaned the
beach it was dirty again you know that's
when it hit me how big this problem of
packaging waste was ultimately like I
came here with a huge Mission which was
to figure out a solution to this
packaging waste problem I think it was
some time in 2018 when um like everybody
else I was in a 95 still dancing um but
under my Guru um but always wanting um
to understand how I can do something
more than this I was trying to find more
purpose in life uh for me to pursue
entrepreneurship was always a onepoint
decision I see the possibilities when it
comes to entrepreneurship and something
that really keeps me awake you know in a
good
way but only if it is that simple there
is no doubt about entrepreneurs having
to start from zero but being a migrant
entrepreneur often means you have to
begin below
zero a number of people I have met
including myself we have to start from
scratch nobody knows nothing it's like
you're born again I mean in terms of
challenges as a migrant founder I think
a very direct one is that the migrant
journey is designed for employees you
know the barriers to entry are hard
enough for entrepreneurs it's it's it's
it's a really hard um it's really hard
to have success as an entrepreneur um
let alone if you're a migrant you know
you're already you know you've got
language barriers um you're potentially
attacking a little bit of xenophobia
which still probably exists in Australia
I was raised with two sisters you know
so I technically three mothers you know
so even at my home if I want to drink of
water I'll just I want to drink water
and it's just being served to me you
know and here I am mopping a floor in a
foreign world and uh particularly you
feel people are walking in with their
suits and everything you know because I
was in a CBD district and near Colin
street so some of your community people
as well very well dressed up and they
come through and you feel I was just
embarrassed to do that kind of work you
know I mean I came over here from
England eight years ago I was a lawyer
back in the UK and a captain in the
British Army and I ended up picking
fruit doing door the door sales because
I had to start from the beginning almost
um and so for entrepreneurs I think
that's why a lot of migrants come into
the country get drawn into
entrepreneurship because you can go and
build something yourself um and you can
kind of own your own narrative whereas
if you want to try to drop into the into
the job landscape you kind of got to
reset I think to uh having the V
willingness to just talk and open in
front of us that would be the first
thing um so again in our business we are
not selling a product you go and just do
a transaction our is a relationship
business before we do business people
need to know us people need to like us
and then people need to trust us before
any business happens just having that
opportunity for people to open up is not
that straightforward one of the
challenges as a business owner was that
acceptance I think I found that Journey
a bit challenging ing because just like
anybody else you always want to be
accepted you've got to get the trust of
the people so that took a while because
it's not just the clients that we're
talking about it's also the community um
so reestablishing myself back in that
landscape was
challenging it's like sometimes we feel
that um we get more criticized or
analyzed by our own
race Social Challenges may be be a
subjective problem but financial support
is very much an objective issue
disparities are still persistent the
overall system needs many changes to
make it supportive for
entrepreneurs for example before
2021 the rules for um visas for
entrepreneurs were so impractical that
my migration agent told me that I was
naive and ridiculous for even thinking
about startup actually said don't waste
your time cuz the whole system wouldn't
benefit it so um I really close to a
Founder at the minute um she um is a
first generation migrant from the
Philippines um so her family moved here
I think 30 40 years ago um and you know
she was born here but it's really facing
that um that challenges both a female
and as um a migrant um and a person of
color in terms of um starting her
business so she's currently fundraising
um and finding all that kind of
unconscious bias um is really impacting
her journey as an entrepreneur and I
think for her it's you know we there's
so much work around that diversity space
in terms of gender which is amazing it
needs to change the dial um but she
thinks that for her personally it's the
bigger challenge is not being a woman
it's it's her um it's her background in
terms of where she's from a big
challenge uh for us right now is of
financial support it's been a struggle
trying to get funding even though there
are those systems that technically exist
yeah does that
work it's a good question that does it
work because it works which means does
funding happen yes funding happens but
it's who does the funding go to right
and where does the where do people
actually get the information or where do
they get the support this year funding
in terms of investment into female
founded businesses was 2% of overall
fund now at start of Victoria our
membership is 42% female and we're
generally a very early stage
organization because that's when
founders need the most community so how
does 42% translate to 2% of the funding
there's obviously somewhere where
there's a huge disparity happening it is
a bra thing to start a business but just
because you are good at something does
not mean you will be good at running the
business it's one of the things I think
most Founders don't do is really
understand why they're building a
business if you understand the why
behind you're building a business it
becomes really apparent to you what you
want to do and what you want out of it
um quite regularly brilliant people with
awesome ideas great innovators but they
don't have the Commercial background in
terms of how to do business um those
areas are especially we see a lot of
people who struggle to commercialize
their business and actually make it
successful beyond the idea stage in
order to maintain the right balance
between goals risks and opportunities
having a realistic mindset is
necessary I think there are two sides to
the coin when it comes to migrants
they've actually gone ahead and proven
that they're resilient they're adaptable
so these are all qualities of a great
entrepreneur anyway right so there's
they've already got these qualities
proven these qualities already we tend
to overestimate the negative impact of
what could be and we totally forget or
maybe
underestimate what good that can do and
so when we tell this story that if I
take the plunge if I do something on my
own I have more negative insights into
me than the positive ones and that sort
of makes me do wrong thing because I'm
not taking a balanced view this is one
thing that I kept telling myself and
this is one A wise man told me and that
wise man is actually my husband he said
to me um there is an audience for madona
there is an audience for Beyonce there
is an audience for Taylor Swift there
will be an audience for chandalia and
that's something that really stuck to me
because uh not everybody gets attracted
to to what you're
offering while the right mindset is
essential personal Drive often acts as
fuel because although discipline can
keep you going only emotions give you
that
kickart it's almost like you got a chip
on your shoulder because in two ways one
is you want to
prove to the new the host country and
you want to prove that you can do
something the second part is you left
your parent country people have
different expectations maybe you have
told them why you're leaving and maybe
what you're doing here is not what you
told them why you're leaving so you also
have a point to prove to them because
when I was in uni I used to walk 2 and
A2 kilometer to buy my groceries and
walk back with all the groceries because
that way I can save money on ticket
because I can use that money towards
buying groceries because there were
times I had no money to eat food and one
of my biggest um influences is my mother
or was my mother still is my mother um
and um in 2018 when I decided to decided
to take the plunge I got this very bad
news that my mom um was diagnosed with
breast cancer and uh that really pushed
me back so I started to embark on this
journey of starting the school and I
named it after her little did I knew
that I was going to lose my mother that
very same year so that was one of the mo
the worst emotional Journeys I have felt
in my life because um this was a tribute
to her and I wanted her to see it um
while she was alive and sadly she
couldn't but I know every day she's
she's up a about looking and um really
loving this journey that I've created
for myself and for others uh and it's
been such a a gratifying experience
because if not for her this this
wouldn't have happened um yeah I'm
completely gratified I think it's um one
of the best things I've done for me um
for my family
um and I feel I'm doing this it's a
purpose it's a very strong purpose that
I've got sorry it's
just no it's
[Music]
okay while there are strong reasons for
their entrepreneurial Journey not
everyone is inclined to become a
unicorn the story of multinationals and
unicorns is also the story of the rise
in economic inequality monopolies and
consolidation entrepreneurship is
fundamental to a truly Democratic
Society the Unicorn narrative needs to
change yeah I think that the Unicorn
narrative is really
damaging um you know we meet a lot of
Founders that have or entrepreneurs that
have an idea um and they start to come
into the ecosystem and they straight
away think there's either failure or
becoming a unicorn and they're the only
two options being a unicorn I think has
been um become a fashion now there's a
lot of things that go into these aspects
and so being tied to that dream of a
unicorn or a decacorn I think makes it
very difficult for people to to really
see what success means so defining your
success very very at the very start is
important and then sort of thinking
about what is making it big for you
really look like I think there's a
necessity for more education in what it
means to what it is to define success
for you and how to have a good strong
Business Without trying to go reach too
high and falling over like there are
lots of unicorns out there that have
still yet to show how to make profit
even many years into it and as shim
saying they burn so much supposedly to
create value but the if the value that
they create is kind of questionable
something that's important to us is
growing sustainably and obviously we
want to make money and we want to be
successful but at the same time we want
our sustainable impact to be tied to our
bottom line so that's something that's
important as we
scale there are startups and small
businesses which are not just about
making a profit their definition of
success is different
it is Equitable it is
inclusive collaborating with art
organizations to create meaningful
conversations about social economic
issues through ART giving out really
strong messaging um i' that's that is
success to me and at the end of the day
success to me is am I fulfilled is my
purpose here fulfilled so everything I
do is with people I love people I care
for
and you know so to
me all of that needs a significant hard
work you know so but while that is
success but it's continuous Journey you
know and um always I always say people
need to have something that they are
really chasing and for me my big thing
that I'm chasing is always to be better
than better tomorrow than I was
yesterday and for that I need to work
today
it's not always you have to be a unicorn
you can be a zebra company if you want
to it's a small business sustainable
business because end of the day I think
when you look at the failure and fear of
it Define what is failure for you define
what is success for you if your business
is contributing something in society if
it is making people's life better you're
a success if you're contributing in
someone else's dream to make them happen
that's a success if you're contrib
buting towards sustainability doing
something for a larger ecosystem it's a
success I think personally I've grown
massively um in a in a in in a mental
capacity um I look at life so
differently now it's not
a 9 toy anymore it's a
24/7 uh of how to and and 24/7 in a very
happy way you know I'm not cornering
myself and oh my God I don't know what
I'm doing no oh my God what is the next
thing we could do to empower these
people how can I inject more cultural
diversity here all the setbacks the
failures um the emotional dramas all of
that is has really fine-tuned me as a
person as an artist as a teacher as an
entrepreneur that the conversations and
relationships I would any
day um cherish all of that when we asked
a lot of entrepreneurs same question
like you have gone through so many
hassles uh so many low movements High
movement what do you think whether it
was worth
it very interesting question because for
my experience like throughout every
milester on this journey whether zero
tag will play out in terms you know
financially you know that's something
we'd have to see I do know that I've
made my life so much harder by trying to
do something new if we can do that right
and just like then definitely be super
worth it yes I mean definitely I
feel this journey irrespective of what
the outcome is I've learned a lot when
you're going through something you feel
all the pain in the world I know the
price I have paid for it without that I
wouldn't have what I have but when I
look
back it is it is worth it oh 100%
100%
absolutely one day my boss told me like
Drop okay stop everything stop
everything then I was like what what's
up then she was like okay come with me
you need to understand why we do what we
do she brought me to this beach clean up
but the organizers actually didn't want
to called it the cleanup it was a beach
audit there was a huge study being
conducted they needed to survey the
Marine litter and hour after we cleaned
the beach it was dirty again and you
could see the plastic rolling with the
waves and you know what was crazy was
that people were fishing
there you know the idea of just even how
you fish just putting a spring and in
getting a fish it's just kind of like
magic but now what if the environment
was filled with
plastic like how could we even get food
that's when it hit me how big this
problem of packaging waste was
ultimately like I came here with a huge
Mission which was to figure out a
solution to this packaging waste
problem I'm Joseph I'm co-founder of
zero tag my name is shimrat John Thomas
and I am the co-founder of zero tag we
are uh in the business of Designing
Technology for
sustainability and um we are trying to
make refill shopping mainstream you know
my background is more in like
engineering and design when I was in
high school uh I I was a painter so yeah
that is a question which uh it's always
changing as in I had a very
multi-disciplinary background so worked
as an architect for a while then mainly
worked as a photographer as well and
photographer and a filmmaker moved on to
design and everything in the design
field as well from branding to UI uh
user inter interaction design things
like that after doing my master because
it's been more of uh looking at new
biomaterials and now yeah zero tags a
culmination of all of those sort of uh
learnings really I didn't want to study
art because I felt that I wanted to see
more of the world if I went into art I
would have learned more about how to
create stuff but then I wanted to see
the world more and maybe even change the
world and I was studying architecture
and working as an architect as well I I
found you know that a lot of the
existing construction materials in the
market were highly unsustainable well
Muni I started creating this Affinity
with the um the Homer industry in the
Philippines part of that was you know I
got matched with a homer company
somewhere in a different island of the
Philippines that focused on sustainable
materials and that's actually where my
journey to sustainability started okay
hello and welcome to manaa you are
currently at Henda crafts I am currently
at Henda crafts um there's just
something about sharing coast and
realizing how connected everyone is so
even for example like at that uh Beach
audit Beach cleanup you know some of the
packaging we found there had like
foreign languages on it and it made me
wonder like how far did this
plastic you know drift and then
realizing how everyone is connected by
water just think of packaging packaging
is is such a complicated thing where
it's like it's functional until you're
finished with the food so there is that
just like realizing this is a huge
problem and I'm in this unique position
to do something about it by having that
background in materials that background
industrial design and even the whole art
thing like maybe I can do something
about it so I needed to learn more about
technology so technology was one of my
weaknesses I think like something I knew
nothing about and that the Philippines
was not ready to teach me so that's why
I came to
Melvin I took my master of design
innovation technology at
R um I had this class and this is where
I met shim Roth all about you know
sustainability biod design and we're
looking at biopolymers and all that
basically we we came up with this
project that involved this reasonable um
packaging for wine um and I started
going to places outside of the classroom
and that's also started our
entrepreneurial Journey we wanted to try
to tackle packaging waste and looking at
the Australian context we found that uh
a huge waste generator in Victoria was
actually um the wine industry we we
initially wanted to go down that path of
creating a new material but we realized
that's going to be really expensive
that's when we realize you know maybe we
can focus on the ReUse angle and try to
use that label system that we thought of
to scale it across the food
manufacturing sector and create a
software which can uh help tackle this
issue
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
our journey started with wine where we
started where we created the reusable uh
bioplastic packaging made from wine
waste uh and that's where we actually
learned about the importance of uh
labels and digital labels we we realized
that that concept could be carried
forward into other food products we try
different ways to validate you know I do
things like have a house party or even
like my birthday and then have people
over and then little do they know is
that you know they might I might have
let's say um wine that was actually from
a refillable wine place and seeing how
that would how people reacted for
example when it came to let's say you
know there's this one day I brought I
brought this huge bottle of beer at the
end of the night nobody touched it I was
like H okay interesting and then so I
asked like the people were still around
hey guys like you don't have like a huge
bottle of moond doog beer here and
they're like oh moond dog beer I love
Moon beer yeah there's like a whole
bottle of ice bucket and then they're
like oh that thing like to be honest it
looks sus that's when I realized how you
know something like the like branding
which is usually like a huge function of
these artworks was also important in
driving consumer confidence something
that was missing in the shopping
experience was the actual artwork as
well as the stories of the the wine and
why people would buy spend $30 on a
bottle which has no name or No Label so
we want wanted with our solution in zero
tag we could communicate uh that
information in a really visual manner
with milk it was more about uh expiry
dates so we after speaking to a lot of
people and uh and customer like
Millennials and Millennial parents we
realized that a lot a big common problem
that they all faced was they would
forget their milk and it would go
spoiled and they or something that we
thought could really help them was
sending them notifications and reminders
to help them avoid this problem and
they're like oh yeah these are the ones
that have the most problems it's like
okay so you know we just wanted to solve
a problem so yeah like store owners that
you know have like Bulk Food Stores Cafe
owners that are promoting sustainable
products and other refill sort of
dispensaries they've been the businesses
we've been talking
to hey oh you yeah yeah you too been a
while uh I'm Luke Phillips um we're here
at into coffeein carry um where zero Way
Cafe and then Studio we've recently got
zero tag on board two coffee uh which
we're really excited about um being zero
waste we have take away milk take away
coffee beans obviously take away coffee
so having a better more transparent and
reliable system around that is is really
exciting zero Tes providing
that trying to reduce friction points
and make reusable containers a enjoyable
experience uh and the big barrier for
that is challenging convenience culture
uh and they're doing a really amazing
job at really reducing those friction
points and making it a really
pleasurable experience start to
end we opened up partly because we recog
Rec that there's an amazing Community
around uh the local area that are
working to solve these sustainability
problems uh and we wanted to build a hub
to bring those people together but also
use that Hub as a bit of a a laboratory
to
tr single use Plastics like straws
plates Cutlery and cotton Bud sticks
will be banned from retail in Victoria
from February the 1st single-use
Plastics make up about uh a thir third
of our waste but most kinds of
disposable drink cups and Lids are
exempt disposable cups and Lids have
plastic elements to make them waterproof
that's why more than 1 billion still end
up in landfill nationally each year so
let's say look this is a paper
cup as you can see it actually has a
plastic lining on it well how do you
think that paper was supposed to be
holding liquids anyway and you think of
your coffee cup moisture it's like it
it's hot and also has liquids that's
like the perfect recipe to start
biodegradation how do you think it would
it would work to begin with like I think
that we're actually so far from creating
that ideal sustainable packaging that
will solve all the problems and for us
like reuse is the one that makes the
most sense and from a sustainability
perspective my background is materials
engineering and um something that I'm
quite frustrated about is how you know
even in engineering how sustainability
is talked about know I had to like learn
that sustainability is it's not a
material property it's contextual it's
about systems let's say oh we have
compostible plastic right and then there
was like a way that they Define
compostible and then like oh okay check
mark and then so if it like check this
box then must be sustainable and then
turns out that well the system for it to
compost was actually highly unlikely to
ever happen um in reality it still
produced microplastics that still harm
the environment but you know if you're
like in marketing right and then you're
this is what the engineers are saying
then it's say okay then I'll just
promote this as a green material and now
now you have so much pessimism of
greenwashing so we're hoping to simplify
that by saying you know what how about
you just reuse and we'll take care of
the rest we zero tag will play out
financially you know that's something we
would have to see right now I've
designed it so that it will and also
designed it so that a sustainable
impactful scale as well if we can do
that right and just like then definitely
be super worth it over the last few
decades single-use Plastics have become
the norm and it's just more convenient
so and that's just made life easier for
everyone but at the same time if you
want to change those habits you need to
create a new system
which can make life easier for everyone
and to do that you need to be able to as
a designer or look at things from
different perspectives it's not just
about creating a product it's about
creating understanding what each
stakeholder sort of wants I understand
why actually this problem is so hard you
know um what I don't agree with is going
complete activist mode and saying well
you know this problem of wayte is
because of people don't care enough
seeing the other side of things as well
you can have people that care but just
nobody has a solution and sometimes
someone has to come up with a good
enough solution and that's where I feel
like my whole responsibility is cuz I
was like I mentioned like my background
is so unique and I feel like this is
that unique perspective I can give to
the world there's just something about
creating also that can just shut people
up about about problems and just say
look this is
possible one of the biggest risk people
take is when they get on the plane leave
the country and the comfort and the
family behind to start everything new in
a new world in a new city new country
where probably they don't even know
anyone that is the biggest risk one
takes in their life but as they come in
as they start settling down they start
forgetting the
dream when I landed here in 2006 you
know that was
a dream that was a dream for me my
family no one in my mom or dad sides of
family has ever gone out of the city I
was the first person in the whole family
to ever get on the plane and leave the
country my name is jerro Sony uh I'm a
founder and director of Sony wealth I'm
from western part of India a city called
Amad so growing up as a child I was very
shy and uh I was very much in my own
cocoon one thing was very important was
to I get to play my you know Cricket
after school every day that was my big
thing on my 11th birthday my parents
gifted me my most expensive toy at that
point in time which was 400 rupees
roughly if I put it dollar value that's
$8 I was always watching Grand Prix and
Formula 1 Sports on uh TV and everything
so cars was always my thing so from that
point on all I always thought that one
day I want to own a Ferrari that was
sort of my dream my toy car was a
Ferrari that my parents gifted I'm 37
now and I still have that toy car with
[Music]
me my dad had a very small business uh
it was a small shop to by to a four
square meter space that's where he
worked all his life I started counting
catch at the age of seven he started
letting me go to the banks from the age
of eight you know so I always involved
in doing things and I always wanted to
do that and he said just focus on your
studies for now you know and when the
time is right you'll do that but my
entrepreneur Journey really started when
I turned 16 and I was really Keen to do
something and uh that's when I started
purchasing you know mobile phones that
because it's pretty new my dad gifted me
one for my birthday and that's we like
okay it's something really great too and
it's the future so I started uh buying
some mobile phones and started selling
them when I turned 18 I got my first job
so I started working in a call center uh
I used to work for BSNL which is a local
like telra here in Australia so I worked
in their call center and then I moved up
to work for Hutch which is WaterOne now
and then two years I worked with
a so I migrated here in 2006 as
international student so when I was
international student I was doing
telemarketing and as soon as as I got
out of uni within the first three months
I purchased my first property I was my
job was to call people and ask them what
do they for do do for living how much is
their income how many properties they
own and every time I used to he they
have two properties or three properties
and they've been here for 10 years my
ears used to go up wow how can you do
that you know because where I come from
people don't even own one property
really it's it's a big deal and there
people were doing so it gave me
something which I call a possibility
that it's possible so I really wanted to
pursue that and I was very lucky enough
to surround myself with right people but
your your dad is so much into business
so much into inventing stuff so there
has to be those jeans somewhere in you
right that's all just surfacing no I'm
only the hardworking part uh we got
married officially a month ago but um
we've been together for nine years um
and also um we work together we have
been working together for the past
almost 5 years the key difference for a
business is it's completely built around
relationship it's for us our journey
really starts with our clients when they
you know purchase the property before we
do business people need to know us
people need to like us and then people
need to trust us before any business
happens so it is a
much much longer Journey before we end
up becoming um uh as business partners
or
clients a lot of people I meet dayto day
and they have a lot of dreams that talk
about and the key differen is when I ask
them are you really interested in
achieving this dream uh and are you
committed to it and most people are
often interested they're not committed
to you know they start getting too
comfortable you know with the job they
have with the income they're earning
with the house they're living in I have
clients that say oh I would love to
drive a MC uh but then somehow they get
satisfied with Toyota nothing wrong with
Toyota but that was the dream to drive a
mer and along the way they just got kind
of lost uh in that comfort zone that
they give a rising you know if you ask
me when I was 16 do I know here I will
be when I turned 38 I had no clue you
know all I knew that all I want better
things in life I want to enjoy some of
the finest experiences in life and then
how never knew never worried too much
about the how it's always the why like I
say right so because of that I enjoy
each phase of my life that was 2006 when
I really got an idea or from a friend
who told me that you know what I can
come here for a further education and
that's when really it struck okay how is
it possible I can't really afford all
this and and they said you can work 20
hours here and that when you work 20
hours you can pay for your lifestyle so
all you need to organize is some money
to pay for your tuition fees and over
the next 5 months every single day me
and my parents they tried everything you
know possible for me to get a Visa we
had to go and ask people for help and my
dad was willing to do that my dad is
someone who has never really asked
anyone for help but he went to some of
his uh clients his friends and say look
my son wants to go overseas for study he
needs a sponsor can you please help and
sponsor him uh for this you know so that
was the first time I saw my dad really
getting out of his comfort zone the
moment I landed here I knew that okay
what is my main purpose I came here and
I one of the key things was I've seen my
dad the way he worked and I wanted to
ensure that I can help him to retire you
know in next 5 years that was my key
goal I was coming from a corporate C
career so I was quite successful in what
I was doing uh before I landed in this
uh City but it wasn't the same I thought
I have all those badges with me so I was
very happily showing my resumés with all
my experience and everything and I was
like I'll get a job very easy it wasn't
that first job that I landed was working
in a 7-Eleven and I had to do 10 shifts
on trial before they would they offered
me a role for for $10 an hour and I used
to cry because I have to mop the floor
I've never lifted a mop in my life I was
raised with two sisters you know so I
technically at three mothers you know so
even at my home if I want to drink a
what I want to drink water and it's a
being served to me you know and here I
am moing a floor in a foreign world and
uh particularly when you see some of
your community people as well very well
dressed up and they come through and you
feel I was just embarrassed to do that
kind of work work you know then why did
you stop cuz I needed the money you know
I needed to work to ear money to buy
food for myself and I said I need to
keep pushing harder because why am I
here what's my goal and that's to retire
my dad and pay for my tuition fees and
bunch forward he's good at getting out
of his comfort zone I feel in general
I'm someone that really likes to stay in
the comfort zone but but with him
I guess he's come very far so he's
evolved over all these years by stepping
out of his comfort zone as I kept
progressing through all of those things
despite of how I was feeling that gave
me more
opportunities you know and so that's why
I always say when you are in your
comfort zone it's easy to hold on to
what you know it's easy to give on your
dreams basically you know but if you
really know that this is what you want
to do you have to commit yourself to get
out of
the one of the key things I did when I
established Sony wealth was to create a
platform where I can bring like-minded
people who can taste what I have tasted
because it's possible and that will also
enable us to go and reach a lot of
people who needs help doing that which I
thought when I'm doing a job you kind of
limited to a task or a job that assigned
to you
it's often considered something very
fancy in nowadays when people talk about
entrepreneurship you know but the
reality is being an entrepreneur is not
an easy Journey To Me entrepreneurship
is not an overnight thing it is a
lifelong thing and you have to give in a
lot before you can build
[Music]
something he he reads he um watches
inspirational clips and also cooking
shows street food cooking shows um I
find it funny that uh you know many many
boys that they would um you know play
video games or um whatever to to to
relax themselves um um in the spare time
and all that he watches cooking shows I
always believe it's just not about
hustling hustling 24/7 you also need to
learn to switch off you know if you
can't switch off if you can't disengage
yourself from everything that goes into
your day it becomes very hard to keep
performing at your level best say if I'm
doing some um housework at home I would
hear the background of people cooking in
the work and explaining what's to put in
ingredient and he's watching that as as
his his um therapy so that's something
he he does as well that because being an
entrepreneur you have to give your 100%
but try your best to give you 100% every
single day and for you to do that you
have to learn for me my downtime is
really enjoying nice glass of whiskey
watching Bollywood movie watching
Cricket cooking you know so I find time
to do all of this throughout my day I
showed a glimpse to Deepak and he
doesn't remember the top most challenge
for me in our business having the right
people because a business is not built
by the business owner it is built by the
team that that they have so finding the
right key people to go with you on the
journey is one of the biggest challenge
it was a long journey so while I have a
great team but it's built over the last
10 years one of the common quality that
my team has is their genuine passion to
help and they're willing to go out of
the way to make sure that things work
practice you have to consciously make an
effort to do this if there's no dream
what's the
purpose you know what's the purpose of
life if you don't have a dream you know
and if you're not working towards
something what are you working towards
if you have a car you have a nice
fanciest car you know how to drive yes
you can get in the car you can start
your car you can start driving but if
you don't know where you're going to you
will you'll get somewhere but that might
not be the place where you want to get
but if you have a dream if you know your
destination this is where I want to get
to even though you face few hurdles like
I faced this morning I was trying to get
in here and three of Ubers ditched me
halfway through the Journey and then I I
had to pay a surge amount to get here
but I know I need to get here and that's
the same thing when you start
visualizing your dreams when you start
working to word said you know because
you're working towards something anyways
you might as well work towards something
that you want to really get to look
success to me is ongoing you know it's
it's a journey it's not a destination
the life I live right now to me is a
dream you know but a dream that I
visioned for where I live is where I
vision for 12 years ago I want to live
the person that I am living with my my
partner my wife is the person that I
always Vision to be by my side the team
that I have built that I work every
single day with is a team that I
visioned for and you know my dream team
everything I do is with people I love
people I care for and you know so to
me all of that needs a significant hard
work you know so but while that is
success but it it's continuous journey
and I'm always I always say people need
to have something that they are really
chasing and for me my big thing that I'm
chasing is always to be better than
better tomorrow than I was yesterday and
for that I need to work
[Music]
today
[Laughter]
[Music]
Manan
my name Mone I am the founder and the
artistic director of chandraa an Indian
classical and modern contemporary School
in Melbourne the way I look at the
business is it's an institution to
impart um this very empowering art form
in the minds of both The Young and the
experienced so if you were to learn a
language one needs to understand the
ABCs the alphabet in order to be able to
string a word word and then a sentence
and to be able to speak fluently and
that is very much how um we look at
dance we look at bnim is understanding
the nuances the the fundamental
structure of the art um so chandalia
focuses a lot on um instilling that
fundamentals in every
student same time in 2018 when um
like everybody else I was in a 9 to5 if
not more than 9 to5 gigs in it um still
dancing um but under my Guru um but
always wanting um to understand how I
can do something more than this um the
question in my mind started to get more
and more strong because I was trying to
find more purpose in life and one of my
biggest um influences was is my my
mother or was my mother still is my
mother um and
um in 2018 when I decided to decided to
take the plunge I got this very bad news
that my mom U was diagnosed with breast
cancer and uh that really pushed me back
and um in a sense the question of bigger
purpose in life started to occur a lot
more frequent in my head so I started to
embark on this journey of starting the
school and I named it after her little
did I knew that I was going to lose my
mother that very same year um so that
was one of the mo the worst emotional
Journeys I have felt in my life because
um this was a tribute to her and I
wanted her to see it um while she was
alive and sadly she
couldn't um because she passed off in
September and I kind of started this um
started doing the background work
sometime in May June and and she
couldn't be part of that but I know
every day she's she's up a looking and
um really loving this journey that I've
created for myself and for others uh and
it's been such a um gratifying
experience because if not for her this
this wouldn't have
[Music]
happened
during Co there were a few adult
students who wanted to pursue this and
and we went online uh we were completely
our curriculum R ran online on Zoom for
2 years it was twice a week 2 hours
training like you're sweating and that
really changes um the chemical balance
in the body and creates a lot of
endorphins to be generated as a health
professional uh scientifically it is
proven if you learn a new art form or
any new thing in your life your uh
cognition will improve a lot when covid
cases were receding and my mental uh
position at that time was I was was very
tired very lethargic uh not able to
focus and I think in some sense I'd lost
some purpose of life just because of the
whole Co environment and doing what's
required in a dance class I was slowly
able to kind of transform myself and
when um when we when we got our freedom
back bang they were back in the studio
like I'm traveling from nsw every week
and even though it is very uh
challenging for me to travel from there
to here I I I however make this um big
sessions almost every week it's really
fun it calms me and helps me with
Fitness and St
I feel proud of myself because I've been
dancing for a long time and I've gone
this far um so today like you know I I
feel so much I look forward to these
classes however bad day I would have had
during the week every Friday there's
this feeling of ecstasy that I have a
class on Saturday and I want to come
here and learn something new and be a
better version of myself I think that um
that that thought process ESS really
helps me in um uh staying fit mentally
and having very positive outlook towards
life that means you're fully loaded okay
give me 100% look at me as students both
young and experience you know 2+ 2 is 4
3 + 2 is 5 and you know you know the
simple math um but one tends one gets to
apply that in dance so we teach that uh
in in the sense as to how to be to to
render that
beat so rendering the beat has a few
elements there is a footwork that's
primarily going to instigate that the
beat because you're going to strike the
foot on the floor to initiate the beat
but in order to understand that footwork
you need to understand what is the
structure of the beat in the
mind and thirdly you need to synchronize
that bead structure head to toe
and be able to move in a formation and
be able to express through your face so
all of this won't come into play if
you're not able to work through that art
of counting in your mind and that
actually enables your math concept at
another
level
[Music]
take
this one's
actually an inspiration when we had Co
um in the middle of Co and um and um I
have another kind of art that I pursue
as part of my training which is bridging
and that's something I got introduced um
back in the States I know people say
it's fusion and we we stay away from the
word um because everything is fusioned
these days bridging is very particular
because it has 8020 or 703 percentage
where the the prerequisite for that is
Barnum um and it gets um embellished
with uh with different costumes um not
necessarily the Barnum traditional one
um and the music is very different I
think about bridging as a transition
into contemporary if you if you know an
art you could actually and if you know
the Rhythm and the Beats you could
pretty much dance to any tune you know
we I took the lyrics of the song and um
I just translate that into the Nya
component of barim which means facial
expressions and through that we' we've
done a lot more collaborations we've
done Barnum and Hip Hop we've done um a
recent commission we've done with uh
this was very interesting we did with
the maloya um artists uh maloya artist
maloya is from The Reunion Island that's
an art that comes out of that's a dance
form that comes out of Reunion Island
which has a beautiful infusion of of
African Chinese Indian um and French
cultur is infused into it so it was
absolutely mesmerizing to bring in the
Tamil culture um and uh the African
culture and the French culture and we
did a commission for 60 minutes which
was beautiful when people start to
relate to other cultures they have
better relationships because the younger
generation needs to understand um
they're going to be in a group of people
from multiple ethnicities they need to
understand how to relate to each other
how to get along exposing them at an
early age is only going to spark all of
those beautiful conversations there's a
couple of students or a few students at
a very young age um you know living in a
in in a in a country which is uh which
doesn't um majority represent themselves
the feeling of acceptance is very
difficult for for a young person
especially in a in a in a school
environment learning this down
has helped them really reduce their
anxiety and feel more confident about
themselves yeah I like expressing myself
through dance and through different hand
gestures um like
this means like very scared or
surprised I would do
this that's how I Reger my anger with my
friends I show it um my Expressions as
more lively and
more happy but sometimes I get like a
little bit mad so I can also show
through
that and then yeah without saying
anything yeah do they understand yes
they get the message all
right that's the right
one we it's character building so it
teaches you a lot more because all of
those art forms tap into a deeper sense
of yourself um and they really help you
during adverse times when when you're at
the bottommost um part of your life art
will help revive you um it will you have
something to step and then climb up well
for me dancing is all about connection
and connection to three different things
connection to the earth on which we
strike and move on connection to my
culture which I've learned many lessons
from and connection to my body and like
myself I think also connection to my
body is a very important aspect of
dancing I never would have thought this
before I started
dancing like dancing has made me more in
tune with myself and made me learn more
about myself I don't see chandraa
confined to South Asian diaspora it has
to expand beyond that because we are we
are in a very cultural environment um
and collaboration is the key for the
next how many ever years so the more
cultural communities collaborate
creating powerful art and I see
chandalia playing a front and center
role in there collaborating with art
organizations to create meaningful
conversations about social economic
issues through ART that's that is
success to me I feel that that sense of
purpose is just heightening every time
the the conversations the relationships
I would any day uh cherish all of that
you have to believe in what you're
saying and you have to execute the same
and there is no shortcuts you're coming
in to learn something that's really
really Dee rooted in in in culture it's
not just about dance it's about your
entire physical and mental
wellbeing
[Music]
for
fore
[Music]
man
[Applause]
[Music]